we've heard of suffering for your art
but some actors take it to extremes it's
one thing to do your own stunts but it's
another to completely change your body
and drastic ways to nail a roll
some stars eagerly embrace the challenge
of transformation and still feel the
Bern after the filming stops here are a
few movies that seriously damaged actors
bodies Tom Hardy in The Dark Knight
Rises it's abundantly clear that Tom
Hardy isn't afraid of a little hard work
he got into massive shape and broke a
few bones when he played an MMA fighter
in warrior and stayed in shape to play
max in fury road where a co-star
Charlize Theron accidentally broke his
nose but it was as everybody's favorite
vein that he really blew our socks off
wait not that one
this one it was his turn as the beefed
up Bane in the 2012 film The Dark Knight
Rises that Hardy admits was the hardest
speaking with The Daily Beast hardy said
that adding all that muscle weight to
his slight 5/9 frame took a huge toll
saying quote I've probably damaged my
body too much I'm only little if I keep
putting on weight I'll collapse like a
house of cards under too much pressure I
think you pay the price with any drastic
physical changes it was alright when I
was younger to put myself under that
kind of duress but I think as you get
into your forties you have to be more
mindful and quote comic accurate not
even close could still kick our butts
inside out absolutely Matt Damon
encouraged under fire maybe he felt like
he needed to prove himself but early in
his career
Matt Damon lost 40 pounds to play a role
in the 1996 war drama courage under fire
and his body came to regret it
afterwards the rapid weight loss caused
lasting effects with his blood sugar
Damon told Movieline quote I ran six
miles in the morning and six miles at
night and I drink four to six pots of
coffee to be able to run that distance I
wouldn't waver from my diet it got so
bad that when my girlfriend kissed me
I'd have to wash my mouth out because I
could taste the oils on her lips from
the food she'd eaten end quote
humble brag about his greasy girlfriend
aside even director Ed's wick was
shocked at how thin Damon got and told
him to eat Damon refused and as a result
Damon had to remain on med
Haitian to moderate his blood sugar for
a year and a half he clearly learned his
lesson for the Martian he simulated his
character severe end of movie weight
loss with digital effects instead of
actual starvation Ben Foster in the
program known as a character actor more
than a leading man then foster shines in
just about whatever he does and is
completely willing to change his
appearance for a role when foster got
the chance to play the disgraced cyclist
Lance Armstrong in the 2015 film the
program he went all in and that included
taking performance-enhancing drugs as
part of his research just like Armstrong
while Foster maintains that the drugs
were legal and taken under doctor's
supervision he told the BBC that
unsurprisingly those drugs messed with
his body for quite a while after the
film was rapped saying quote I had a
great doctor which helped me handle some
of those consequences but it took about
half a year to get my levels right and I
would say for any athlete you have to
ask where are your values and quote
reportedly Foster's own values included
literally eating dirt to get a better
feel for his character in lone survivor
and buying but not taking meth for his
role in alpha dog gotta draw the line
somewhere Matthew McConaughey and Dallas
buyers club Matthew McConaughey has
always been known for his incredible
good looks but these days the actor
seems hell-bent on transforming that
handsomeness into something else and it
all seemed to start with his
oscar-winning performance in 2013's
Dallas buyers club the then 44 year-old
dropped nearly 50 pounds for the role
describing the experience of losing the
weight the actor told the BBC quote I
did it in as healthy away as I found
possible I met with a nutritionist I
gave myself four months to lose the
weight I had my programmed meals lost
three and a half pounds a week like
clockwork and got down to my desired
weight which turned out to be 47 pounds
lighter while McConaughey never
mentioned having any long lasting
problems it did change him a little
because he's never looked quite the same
since see if you even recognize him in
2017 s goals for which among other
things he gained weight chris hemsworth
in in the heart of the sea actor Chris
Hemsworth also took the extreme weight
loss plunge for his part in 2015 in the
heart of the sea where he plays Owen
chase
man stranded at sea the actor lost 33
pounds to accurately convey chases
suffering but he admitted it took quite
a toll on his body and his mind
more so than building muscle wait for
Thor which he told Good Morning America
the guy needs fine you just ate a lot
and he left whites but that was underfed
which led to a pretty moody existence
and inconsistent emotions and so on
Hemsworth only ate about 500 calories a
day consisting of boiled eggs salads end
quote
nothing much as an actor Hemsworth
wanted to play it real in order to do it
justice a story we have to suffer in
some way and we didn't it was you know
there wasn't a whole lot of acting in
court even more impressive Hemsworth was
able to rebound from the extreme change
well enough to return to the extremely
buff extremely Mighty Thor Christian
Bale in The Machinist if there's a prize
for crazy extremes actors endure for
their craft the award goes to Christian
Bale who's known to of really get into
his roles are you doing are you
professional or not do I can walk around
oh shut the [ __ ] up Bruce he gained
weight for American hustle and bulk
tough to play Batman but it was his turn
in the 2004 in DPhil The Machinist that
became his most infamous transformation
to play a person suffering from insomnia
Bale lost 65 pounds by basically eating
a single can of tuna fish or an apple a
day along with drinking black coffee and
water even the health professionals he
consulted with warned Bale to not go too
far but he ignored their advice telling
movie pilots quote I had been to a
nutritionist and when I got down to what
she told me was a healthy weight
I just went you know what I can go more
than this I can keep going so I lost
another 20 pounds below what she said I
should stop at and quote while the
transformation was stunning Bale
explained more of his experience quote I
didn't actually feel bad until I started
eating again it was when I started
putting the weight back on that I did it
somewhat too rapidly you know putting
the weight back on I just wanted to
consume pizza and doughnuts and quote
while Vale managed to bounce back it's a
pretty good bet he won't be taking
another role as a psycho skeleton in the
near future then again who wouldn't want
to see a movie called psycho skeleton
starring Christian Bale
answer no one thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to